it's the last show of 2017 and what a
show it shall be President Trump signs
into law his tax reform nikki Haley
becomes our spirit animal and the
mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show oh yes so much to get to
here on the bench Shapiro show we
finally reached the end of the year
we're here it's upon us and we survived
we all got here you know that was in
doubt all year long it was in doubt over
the last three weeks it was in doubt I
mean I know that I was expected to be
dead at least twice I'm not even talking
about when I visited Berkeley I'm just
talking about the tax reform and net
neutrality but we'll talk about all of
the things that are happening on this
the last workday essentially of 2017 but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at blinka so you're gonna
have some time over the holidays but you
don't have time to read a 500 page book
you don't you have time to listen to a
15-minute segment that basically brings
you all the points of the book cuz
that's all you're gonna remember anyway
well that's what blink astiz for instead
of having to spend all your time waiting
through pages and pages of material
you're in the car anyway there for an
hour you don't have my podcast next week
so what are you gonna do they're driving
to Grandma's house what are you gonna do
all week well this is why you need the
blink a snap the blink a snap
gives you in what they call blinks 15
minutes summaries of the main points of
2000 of the best-selling non-fiction
books in America transforms into
powerful information packs now you can
feast your mind on key ideas from top
best-selling non-fiction books things
like flow which talks about how to
achieve more happiness in your work life
to why nations feel talking about how
nations are run why did I shouldn't else
like a 700 page book taking a week to
complete but if you listen to the bling
cast on it it'll take you like 15
minutes to complete it's been selected
as one of the best apps in America by
Forbes BuzzFeed The New York Times and
it's used by over 3 million users right
now Blinky's has a special offer just
for our audience go to blink accom slash
Ben right now to start your free trial
or get three months off your yearly plan
when you join today that's blink is to
spell bli and K is T blink is calm / Ben
to start your free trial or get three
months off your yearly plan blink is
calm / Ben uses flash pens they know
that we sent you okay so today big day
over at the White House the President of
the United States
signs into law his ginormous tax cut and
everyone is very excited so the
president
signs that into law just before
Christmas and then he says that he's
gonna have a working vacation I hope not
I hope the president just takes the time
off
what's the media Fester you know he
doesn't he doesn't need to provide them
content let them chew on all of the good
things that are happening because of
this tax cut so there is an additional
list we gave you a list yesterday of
corporations they're now giving bonuses
and raises to people and hiring more
people because of the tax cut that just
passed the Senate and the house and was
signed into law by the president in
Texas New Braunfels based rush
enterprises is planning to give each of
its employees a $1,000 bonus after
President Trump signs the tax reform
bill into law the commercial truck
dealer said all of its approximately
6600 US employees will receive the
one-time payout which will cost about
six point six million dollars in
Wisconsin Associated Bank said it would
boost its minimum hourly wage to fifteen
bucks and pay workers a $500 bonus their
current minimum wage is $10 an hour so
that's a fight that's a fifty percent
increase the company said that its moves
would affect about three thousand
employees in Idaho Melaleuca Inc which
is run by frank van der Sloot's an
Anderson Republican he said in a phone
interview that his 2,000 workers would
get a one-time bonus from a hundred
bucks for every year they worked at the
company they have about 150 employees
who have worked there for twenty years
or more the average employee will get
about an $800 bonus in Hawaii the Royal
Hawaiian heritage jewelry that they've
decided to open a second shop and
there's gonna happen all over the place
right then there's gonna happen as
businesses decide they have more money
to spend then hiring should go up
investment should go up even their stock
buybacks maybe jester stocks go up but
it's good for the economy when people
get to keep their own dollars why
because they get to spend those dollars
they invest those dollars and you know
what you want to buy better than the
federal government knows what you want
to buy now the left has lost their mind
over the tax cut obviously they just
can't deal with it and it's really
interesting because it sort of betrays
what they actually think of America and
what they think of your capacity to keep
your own money so Elizabeth Warren for
example you know she has an interesting
take her basic notion here is the reason
corporations are now giving bonuses and
raises is because they're trying to
propagandize to their workers not
because they actually like their workers
or help their workers they have
nefarious motives all of the
corporations are essentially evil in the
end they'll just use that money to line
their own pockets and give the
selves big bonuses that's what they'll
do they're cruel and plutocratic here's
Elizabeth Warren sending a few smoke
signals of her own I want to be
absolutely clear I am delighted when
workers get more money
I'm glad when it happens at any
corporation in America yay
but let's be really clear if these
corporations had wanted to do that they
already had plenty of profits to do it
the idea that this is trickle-down
economics at work rather than just plain
old politics it's just wrong the
corporate CEOs have already told us what
they're going to do with this money give
you an example Home Depot right after
the Senate passed the tax bill a couple
of weeks ago Home Depot CEO is executive
is interviewed instead so what are you
gonna do with all of this money that
Home Depot has because they're going to
do really well on this was it we're
gonna raise wages for our employees mmm
no why is it we're going to hire more
employees at the Home Depot stores no
our was it we're going to build more
Home Depot's across America um no they
said what we're gonna do is we're going
to do stop buybacks in other words we're
going to use whatever money comes in to
pump up the price of our stock okay so
what's hilarious about this is number
one the Democrats were claiming for
years that the stock market growth of
the Obama administration was clearly a
reflection of his underlying solid
economy except the job growth didn't
keep up because the stocks were actually
stock buybacks right now she's ripping
stock buyback stock buybacks are
terrible but the idea here is that
corporations are nefarious their profit
seeking isn't that awful now hilarious
is the same folks who think that
corporations are profit seeking and evil
number one I don't know if they've ever
met anyone who runs a corporation okay I
help run a corporation right I along
with my executive team the people I work
with the presidents of the company and
the CEO the CEO of the company you know
we run the company together we actually
do care about our employees if you went
to our Christmas party yesterday the
only employee who got a bad gift in our
Christmas party was Michael Knowles
because he's a bad employee right he got
coal that I gave him for Christmas but
aside from that it was in a Tiffany's
box so I guess it was nice a little bit
and one day if Michael really puts
himself under pressure that coal will
become a diamond it was actually in
there's me exhorting him to work but
everybody at the company is relatively
happy because we are interested in
keeping them employed and if they are
good at their jobs we give them raises
and if they're good at their jobs we
retain them and if they're bad at their
jobs we fire them people don't want to
fire people okay they actually don't
people are not generally in the business
of enjoying firing people and
corporations actually do care about
their workers which is why wages have
risen in the United States in terms of
what you can buy they've risen in the
United States continuously despite the
death of private sector unions private
sector unions represent something like 3
percent of the workforce now they barely
exist all of the unions exist in the
public sector where they're unionizing
against the government but in the
private sector people have decided that
they're gonna have better luck instead
of unionizing just going and talking to
their employer about arrays which is
correct but the idea from the from the
left is precisely the reverse
corporations are cruel they hate you
they want to harm you they want to use
you as a slave labor but the government
is benevolent
so it's benevolent when the government
comes to me and takes a gun out and
points it at me and says give me your
money that's benevolent but and if the
mutton if the government gives me my own
money back then that's bad that's bad
because you know that's redistributing
the wealth but if a corporation is
working and giving bonuses and keeping
people employed then somehow they're
cruel now here's the thing I think most
people are motivated by self-interest
the difference is that in a capitalist
economy my self-interest does not
manifest as anything good for me unless
I give something to you
capitalism turns self-interest into what
I have called for stala ISM the point
being that I can be as selfish as I want
but if I don't produce a good or service
that you like I'm gonna starve hey
that's the beauty of the capitalist
free-market system government has no
such qualms government has no such
issues if government wants to survive
government can't go bankrupt it will
just bankrupt you it will take all your
money all your children's money if we're
gonna talk about caring levels versus
corporations versus government
corporations care a hell of a lot more
about making sure that you are employed
as long as you are doing work for them
then the government cares no more than
care at all the government will just tax
the hell out of you if you earn and
they'll give you money if you don't
because the government is interested in
your dependency or in sucking money out
of your pocket those are the only two
things the government is interested in
on a fiscal level either taking your
money or turning you into a dependent
those are the only two things government
is not interested in boosting you or
giving you a hand up you know the
Democrats will say we would just wanna
give you a handout because to hand up
then and then they promote policies that
make sure that people stay in poverty
they pay people to stay off the work
lines right they want welfare increased
so that people don't have to work jobs
this is why you have Nancy Pelosi saying
things like we want to make sure that
you are not burdened by job lock lately
you're not locked into a job you don't
want to do okay that fundamental
difference between how you view private
industry and how you view government
undergirds this entire thing and in a
second I do want to discuss what
happened at the UN as a major
development to over at the UN yesterday
with nikki Haley really taking charge
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at us CCA so if you're a
gun lover it's time for you to listen up
how would you like to head to the range
tomorrow with a brand new gun I know you
would it's Christmas time folks I know I
would too well my friends over at the
u.s. CCA want to get more guns into the
hands of more responsible law-abiding
armed Americans like you so they are
ending 2017 by giving you up to 17
chances to win your new gun every day
that's right a different gun every
single day of the week could be a Kimber
could be a lock could be a Springfield
all you have to do is go to defend my
family now three calm defend my family
now judge it three.com to reveal which
gun you could be taking home tomorrow
its defend my family now three.com
remember not a lot of time the gun of
the day will always disappear at
midnight this will be the last time I'm
telling you the website so listen
carefully it's defend my family now
three.com defend my family now 3.com get
your chance to win a new gun every
single day but do it right now defend my
family now three.com go check it out USC
c8 does a lot of fantastic work you
should register with them in any case
okay so yesterday as I said nikki Haley
acting as my spirit animal and she was
at the UN the UN votes 128 to nine
against the United States moving our
embassy to jerusalem's which we say go
to hell who cares what you have to say
why in the world when I care that Yemen
doesn't want us to move our embassy to
Jerusalem and Yemen can kiss our ass who
cares
answer no one no one okay and nikki
Haley made that pretty clear she
basically looked at the entire UN and
she said guys you think I'm standing
here like caring about what you guys
have to say
welcome to murica Nikki hailey doing
yeoman's work over at the UN it's always
weird whenever people speak at the UN it
looks like they're speaking in the
bathroom of the Macy's right Meg there's
there's Nikki hailey really bashing
people about the head United States is
by far the single largest contributor to
the United Nations and its agencies when
a nation is singled out for attack in
this organization that nation is
disrespected what's more that nation is
asked to pay for the privilege of being
disrespected the United States will
remember this day in which it was
singled out for attack in the General
Assembly for the very act of exercising
our right as a sovereign nation we will
remember it when we are called upon to
once again make the world's largest
contribution to the United Nations and
we will remember it when so many
countries come calling on us as they so
often do to pay even more and to use our
influence for their benefit cut them off
cut them off
cut them off okay none of these
countries that are voting against the
United States ought to take their
foreign aid for granted now there are
two types of foreign aid that the United
States grant it represents foreign aid
by the way about 1% of the American
federal budget every year what's
breaking the bank is not foreign aid but
we can use this as a tool you know we
give it like a hundred million dollars
is in Bob way every year like in human
and development aid in health and
development it we give a true it says
something 135 million dollars every year
to Zimbabwe which was until five minutes
ago run by Robert Mugabe one of the
worst people on planet earth there been
studies that show that foreign aid does
virtually nothing when he's trying to
check to a dictator the dictator takes
the check immediately cashes it builds
himself a new palace buys himself a
couple of new female bodyguards and then
goes about his daily business by
stopping the bodyguards and and
murdering his own people four and eight
unless it is specifically to the right
areas doesn't do a whole hell of a lot
and the UN doesn't do a whole hell of a
lot the idea of attaching strings to the
system makes a lot of sense now what's
funny is that there are people on the
Left who don't believe this so Philip
Mudd is one of these people he's a you
know his name is mud literally and he he
actually says this on CNN he said
he said that Trump was acting in the
form of diplomatic prostitution he said
let me be blunt here wolf he said this
to Wolf Blitzer
this is diplomatic prostitution we're
telling people unless you vote with us
we're not going to give you money and if
your heart doesn't agree with American
policies we're not gonna support you in
terms of USA that's not prostitution
it's just called diplomacy like we
actually get to attach strings to the
checks that we sign to people it's true
everywhere by the way it's true in
domestic policy too no such thing as a
free lunch internationally or nationally
and by the but what this really betrays
is that there are a lot of people in the
United States living in the United
States who do not actually see the
United States as a force for good in the
world they don't they see it as a bad
thing they see it as a bad thing when we
exert our power in the world that's
because there are really two different
views of America on the world stage view
number one is that America is a big
bully this was Barack Obama's view and
his apology tour early on in his
presidency in America is the big bully
on the world stage were mean to people
and cruel were overreaching were sort of
bull in a china shop sure we try to do
the right thing but we usually do the
wrong thing and then there is the more
traditional and correct view of
America's role in the world which is
that we are the greatest force for
freedom the world has ever seen and ever
known in fact is where American boots
have set foot freedom follows
I'm not gonna talk about whether we
should have been in every war that we've
been in but where America was present
there was freedom and where America was
removed at the freedom went away this is
true in Vietnam where when we pulled out
of Vietnam South Vietnam and South
Vietnam a free country turns into a
communist tell Ho so does Cambodia in
Cambodia where they were the Khmer Rouge
and at murdering a million people right
when we when we pull out of Korea out of
North Korea North Korea is still a
prison camp 60 odd years later in South
Korea where we still have troops is one
of the freest most prosperous countries
in Asia
forget about your upper I mean all of
Europe would be speaking German right
now for one for the United States
including Britain so the idea that the
United States has been nefarious force
on the world stage that we have strings
attached
we should have strings attached because
our strings are good and our strings are
usually things like we would like you to
free up your press we would like you to
not oppress women we would like for you
to support United States foreign policy
in strengthening our interests around
the world this is good stuff
the United States has never conquered
nations to take them the United States
has conquered nations in order to place
regimes with better regimes ask how
that's gone for Japan and Germany the
answer is pretty well and by the way it
was going a lot better in Iraq until
President Obama decided to precipitously
withdraw from Iraq leaving in his wake
an Iranian backed regime and Isis in the
in the west of the country in the
northwest of the country so this view
that the United States is being terrible
by attaching strings to our funds it's
my money for God's sake it's my money so
it's my money then I get to determine
what happens with it this notion that
the government has a role in taking my
money and then spending it on whatever
stupid thing Robert Mugabe wants to
spend it on it verges on taxation
without representation is the truth now
one of the things that's always
interesting is the the UN votes as I
talked about yesterday statistically
insanely and routinely all the time
they they vote against Israel and a huge
percentage of all the votes they've ever
taken in the own General Assembly are
against Israel and the people who vote
against Israel are typically there are a
lot of people who abstain yesterday the
people who voted against Israel are
largely located in areas with large
Muslim populations Europe or in the
Muslim world itself so they're the voted
I say it 128 to 9 so 57 of those
countries were Islamic so half of them
right off the bat our Muslim countries
that hate Israel and don't believe that
it ought to exist and then there are
another 50 odd countries and some of
those are in Asia and some of those are
in Europe and what you are seeing is
this alliance between members of the
European left and radical Islam to
condemn Israel all right this is where
anti-semitism exists I've talked about
anti-semitism before on the program
there are a few different types there's
religious anti-semitism which is sort of
Muslim anti-semitism at this point
there's still some Christian
anti-semitism but that's become far less
of a problem over the last 50 years
since the Holocaust in Auroville a 70
years since the Holocaust rather there
is Muslim anti-semitism some religious
anti-semitism
there's also secular anti-semitism in
the form of people who do not like
Christianity do not like Judaism they're
okay with Islam because Islam makes them
feel a multicultural and special and
warm inside but they're not big on the
on the unit and this
coming out in Europe so there's a piece
in USA Today talking about Germany
Germany voted against the United the
United States moving our embassy to
Jerusalem again none of their damn
business
again they be speaking Hitler if it
weren't for us but the idea that Germany
is is going to tell Israel a country
full of Jews right about the same
population of Jews come to think of it
as we're slaughtered in the Holocaust by
the Germans and their allies that
they're going to tell Israel where to
put their capital is beyond absurd the
anti-semitism in Germany is on the rise
in Europe it's on the rise so if you
wonder if Israel if the anti-israel
motivation is caused by anti-semitism
the answer is yes
European anti-semitism has long roots
now there's a lot of European
anti-semitism that's based off of new
Muslim migrants and also secular
leftists who believe that Israel is a
nefarious force for Western imperialism
so there's peace in USA Today when
telecommunications manager Mikhail
Tenaya emigrated to Germany in 1998 from
his native Russia as a teen his Jewish
faith didn't matter to classmates her
neighbors but now he says when I arrived
in Germany I never saw such displays but
now there are thousands of people for
burning Israeli flags in the streets in
2006 Germany recorded 1,500 anti-semitic
incidents that was a massive increase
from previous years according to a
recent survey in western Germany 62
percent of Jewish respondents said they
experienced anti-semitism in their
everyday lives 28 percent said there
were victims of verbal attacks or
harassment in the past year when I
visited France my wife and I were afraid
to go in particular districts while I
was wearing a yarmulke I wore a baseball
cap instead when I was in London I think
I've told this story on the show when I
was in London there was a situation
where we went to Madame Tussauds Wax
Museum we're walking around looking at
all the statues no Jewish statues right
except for Albert Einstein and behind us
there's a group of young Muslims you can
tell cuz the woman's wearing a hijab she
ran by two guys who are who also looked
like they are from Muslim countries and
they actually walk up to the Statue of
Albert Einstein start strangling it and
I figured well maybe they just don't
like the theory of relativity turns out
not there's also a wax statue of Hitler
and while every British person there was
walking over and strangling Hitler these
young Muslims went over and put their
arms around Hitler like he was uncle
Hitler and began taking pictures
anti-semitism
on the rise there it's on the rise in
places like Sweden not just because of
radical Islam but also because of a
secular movement that sees religious
education as backwards and non
progressive Nordic countries maintain
opinion corridors for acceptable ideas
in the public square and those opinion
corridors do not include religious
people very often so anti-semitism
anti-israel sentiment it may be true
that not everyone anti-israel is
anti-semitic but everyone anti-semitic
is certainly anti-israel and there is
pretty significant crossover between the
two groups okay well as we continue I
want to get to the mailbag I want to do
a particularly long mail back it's a
year-end mailbag now and give you a
chance but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at nature box so
the holidays mean that it is time to do
things right you need to wrap your gifts
you need to travel you need to plan that
travel you embrace for your relatives
you need extra energy and that's why you
need nature box nature box has over 100
delicious snacks all the snacks are made
with high-quality simple ingredients no
artificial colors flavors sweeteners
just go to nature box calm and nature
box will deliver them directly to your
door they add new snacks every single
month inspired by new food trends
professional chefs customer feedback now
folks at the office they particular like
the vanilla bean wafers dried mango and
coffee kettle popcorn we took a quick
survey of the office and those are the
ones that are the most popular there is
no risk by the way if you don't like a
snack naturebox replaces it for free
there's a reason that everybody around
here is obsessed with nature box right
now nature box is offering ben shapiro
fans 50% off your first order
when you go to nature box common 50% off
your first order nature box common also
makes a really good Christmas gift you
have somebody in your family who's
constantly on the run nature box common
gets you a 50% discount on your first
order which can be your Christmas gift
to them nature box common check it out
live a more delicious energy filled life
okay so I'm not gonna do things I like
things I hate in the mail bag today
instead I'm gonna do lots and lots of
mail bag game we're just gonna mail bag
it up yo so we'll jump right in and
we'll take your live questions as well
so everything will be everything will be
fascinating and we will go through as
many questions as possible before the
end of the year so we begin with Makayla
she says dear Ben every time the
Republicans talk about taxes Chuck
Schumer comes out and explains that
trickle-down economics have never worked
I've googled this to try and find proof
that it has in order to educate my
brainwash fellow Millennials to no avail
could you please explain in an objective
way the actual pros and cons of
trickle-down economics and when it has
actually shown growth so the reason that
first of all let's start with a problem
with Google if you google trickle-down
economics you are only gonna get the
failures of trickle-down economics
that's because it's a quote a term that
was not coined by the right it was a
term that was coined by the left those
right calls it supply-side economics
book up supply-side economics on Google
and you will come up with a myriad of
examples in which supply-side economics
has worked supply-side economics is the
idea that if you give producers back
their money they're going to produce new
and better products and that generates
its own demand supply generates its own
demand basically so if you generate
cheaper product not crap nobody wants to
buy but if you make products cheaper and
better people will want to buy it if you
invent new products that changes the way
people live everybody wants to buy it 15
years ago 20 20 years ago nobody never
heard of an iPhone now everyone has one
that's because of supply side Apple
created a product you wanted the product
you went out and bought the product what
the Left likes is what they call demand
side economics demand side economics is
the idea but if you give a bunch of
money to a bunch of people that they'll
spend that money and that will jog the
economy it won't jog the economy in the
sense of making people's lives better
generally because the products aren't
gonna get any better right the point
being that maybe here's the great
distinction if you have a million
dollars you give it to let's say that
all else is equal right nobody has a
million dollars we're not talking about
and we're not talking about equality now
we're just talking about jogging the
economy talk about efficiency you have a
million dollars you give a million
dollars to Bill Gates to invest in the
building and invention of new product
nor do you give a million dollars $1 to
a bunch of people so they go spending on
a burger which is gonna make the economy
better the answer is you give the
million dollars to Bill Gates the reason
is that Bill Gates is then going to
create a product that makes everybody's
life better that will create a bunch of
new jobs in a growing area where people
are opting for the product that's not a
case for impoverishing people of course
but the point that I am making is that
producers businesses change the economy
at disproportionate levels right so
supply-side economics has generated
success after the JFK tax cuts generated
economic success after the Reagan tax
cuts in eighty-one generated economic
success after the bush tax cuts of 2001
there was sustained economic growth
people tend to forget this because of
the crash in 2007-2008 and even Barack
Obama maintained
tax rates in 2010 and 2013 so
supply-side economics does indeed work
it's worked in Europe it's the reason
why Denmark for example is now cutting
its own taxes it's why European
countries that have spent too much money
are cutting their own taxes so don't
Google trickle-down that's it's a
nonsense term made down made up by the
left the idea would be that people at
the top of companies are just gonna give
the money to their employees that's not
correct that's not how trickle-down
works right supply-side means that
you're creating new products and
services and in the course of doing so
it creates jobs Tina says hi my husband
just bought me a Christmas present a
subscription to The Daily wire yay well
thank you your husband's awesome what a
great husband you should probably give
him a ring I do have a burning question
are your kids as smart and analytical as
you in other words is there hopefully my
children's generation and how can we
battle the liberal teachers school
school districts that are brainwashing
our kids six hours a day well as far as
the brainwashing from the schools I
would suggest private school
homeschooling take over your local
school board you really do have to be
very very involved as far as are my kids
are smart analytical as I am my three
and a half year old it's hard to tell
when for the one to half year old boy
because that suits just am I mean he's
just running around the whole time like
I haven't seen a lot of analysis from
him other than know and also cheese he
really likes cheese but aside from that
he I mean he he's he's obviously a very
smart kid he's really highly developed
in terms of language
my daughter is brilliant leah is is
super smart my son may be brilliant I
just don't know yet he's not speaking
full sentences
she is really really intelligent I mean
she's four she's not even four she's
already started her violin lessons she
can essentially read she she knows her
numbers and she her thought processes
are all quite rational so she's she's
very smart okay Arya says hi Ben what do
you think Trump can do at this point to
maintain the House and Senate next year
okay so what Trump can do is shut up I
mean nothing is what Trump has to do
Trump needs to be quiet well because if
he keeps talking it makes him more
unpopular also he needs to go out and
talk about his accomplishments he needs
to he needs to go out and talk about how
to unify Americans he can have fun but I
think that it's a mistake for him to I
think it's a big mistake for him to go
on Twitter and use Twitter the way that
he has the past year I'm hoping that
we're beginning to see some discipline
from Trump listen there will be losses
in the house but those losses can be
mitigated if yeah
climate continues to be good and if
Trump can make himself less unpopular
he's never gonna be super popular he's
never gonna get up to 55% in the
approval ratings but right now according
to I think was Rasmussen this morning's
up to 44 if he can get that up to 47 48
he'll do fine and Republicans will do
fine okay Emanuel says any word back
about the rosy harassment so what he is
referring to is that today sadly Rosie
O'Donnell has some sort of sad
obsessions had sexual obsession with me
which is horrifying in every conceivable
way and she tweeted out yes I told you
yesterday that she tweeted that she
wanted me to suck her bleep but her
bleep was a male genitalia which is
weird and I responded that she should
stop being homophobic and sexually
harassing people me too
and then she and then she tweeted again
today that she wanted me to lick her
which to which I tweeted no means no
Rosie you know and all victims have a
right to be believed hashtag me too
and and then I reported her to Twitter
not because I actually want her banned
from Twitter suspended from Twitter as
I've said before I didn't want Milo
banned or suspended from Twitter I think
that if I were running a place I pretty
much wouldn't suspend anybody except for
explicitly violent behavior but I do
want to see if Twitter is just going to
have a radical double standard right if
they're gonna ban people on the right
for saying stuff like Rosie said like if
I'd said that to Rosie is there any
question they would have suspended her
ban Bay no question
none Rosie says it to me totally fine so
we will find out rosie has blocked me so
I guess that she has moved on from her
sexual obsession so that's that's sad
it's it's sad that number one it was
unrequited number two don't sexually
harass people she did her parting shot
to me was something to the effect of she
didn't even know who I was but I look
like a little boy so which eye responds
and then why are you sexually
propositioning a little boy because
that's that's creepy and terrible okay I
my twitter was pretty fired this week
okay so Nathan says hey Ben looking good
today thank you sir of course he says
how would you define Zionism and do you
consider yourself a Zionist thanks bro
yes I consider myself a Zionist Zionism
is the idea that the that the Jews
deserve a state of their own in biblical
Israel I'm a Zionist because I am a Jew
and Jews like a Jew who believes in
Judaism not because
ethnically Jewish and Judaism is a
Zionist religion that suggests that
there should be Jewish rule in the Holy
Land and that it was a biblical promise
now what's interesting is people take
that to mean that there has to be a
kingship in the Holy Land the Bible is
as I've said before I think I talked
about it this week in the Bible segment
the Bible is really ambivalent about
state power it is it is not big on the
idea of theocracy per se but it's the
idea that there ought to be a Jewish
state based on foundational Jewish
principles it's true for a few reasons
among them anti-semitism and the and the
tremendous outpouring of anti-semitism
that is existed throughout history and
also the idea that a country ruled by
Jewish principles will be a good country
just like a country ruled by Christian
principles in the United States is a
good country here into a little bit more
of the mailbag in just a second so but
first you know I think I'm gonna have to
break here on YouTube and Facebook so
let's let's do that
so for $9.99 a month you can get the
rest of this mailbag and things I like
in things I hate and I have a Christmas
message for you that you're going to
want to see today so for $9.99 a month
you can get your subscription to daily
wire you get the rest of the mailbag get
to be part of the mailbag you get to be
part of our show live you get everything
that you could possibly want in life
except for the thing that you get with
the annual subscription which is that's
the very greatest in leftist tears hot
or cold
Tumblr's it is the greatest okay it's so
great that front of Christmas gifts we
got everyone each Tumblr's here at the
office and people were literally weeping
I mean people Austin loves it everyone
loves it it did people that people are
breaking down they couldn't believe it
there's like that episode of Oprah where
she gave away cars except it was just a
cup but you can get that for $99 a year
you get the annual subscription and it's
pretty awesome and the Shapiro store is
coming I promise I know I know it's
coming okay guys yes it's coming okay so
you get all that from the annual
subscription as well $99 you're cheaper
than the monthly and please subscribe at
SoundCloud iTunes over it over at Google
Play or stitcher check us out over there
and subscribe to our youtube channel as
well where we have a Christmas video out
today that is simultaneously humiliating
in hilarious so if you want to see me
dramatically humiliated then go check
out that Christmas video as well by
subscribing to YouTube we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so Morgan asks Ben when your
kids are old enough to watch Star Wars
will you show them in the order you sum
them as a child or in the order of the
saga
good question Morgan so my wife was not
super familiar with Star Wars so I have
put her on a remedial Star Wars course
and I started her with episode 4 I will
never start any child on episode 1 why
would i torture a child that way
that's cruelty to animals and children
don't do it yeah also the reason is
because you have to actually care about
Luke and Darth Vader and all these
people before you go back and do Anakin
all right that's it's foolish to start
with with episode 1 I believe also
because Star Wars Episode one
I mean Phantom Menace is just garbage
Phantom Menace is awful it's a real
battle for worst movie ever between that
and Attack of the Clones whoo both both
stinkers Austin has a question Wow okay
so where do I slap dog one I answered
this a few days ago but Austin although
he's a producer on the show obviously
was not listening so right he was not so
rogue one I slot at number three I like
rogue one a lot so oh where do you watch
it so okay so in order I would probably
watch it now I would probably watch four
five six three Road one eyebrow watch
the road one afterward because it's the
lead-in and then I'd probably go back
and watch one two three and then Force
awakens in the last Jedi so it's
completely out of order but once you've
watched the movies you can slide them
all in and there's something that's fun
and discoverable about it that way if
you watch throw one and then you just
watch the episode four you'd miss how
cool rogue one is right because if you
watch rogue one and then episode four
then it just fits right in but the whole
point is that they Reese lot it in a new
movie which is super cool and then it
transitions right into episode four
which is really awesome okay Keenan's
has been what is your favorite thing
that Trump has done this year well it
justice Gorsuch the moving of the
embassy to Jerusalem the cuts and
regulations the the tax bill getting rid
of the individual man and he's done a
lot of good things this year he's done a
lot of good things this is this is a big
gap for Trump is that so much of his
policy is good and so much of his
rhetoric is horrible that if he can get
his rhetoric you know in a better
direction then it won't be very hard to
support him will it okay Eliot says hey
Ben simple question for you should
people on welfare be allowed to vote no
representation without taxation so
people on welfare should be allowed to
vote and also there should be no law
that's it that's basically my my take
not because because I think that if you
if you're a navab iding citizen in the
United States then you should have the
right to vote but I also think that the
Constitution was designed to prevent
welfare and I think that we are gonna
have to make a move to convince people
that they are not that they should not
be dependent on government the barrier
by the way between the presence of
welfare and the non presence of welfare
I do not think as people who are on
welfare I don't think it really is as
simple as everybody on welfare votes
Democrat and everybody not on welfare
votes Republican I think that we're
gonna have to make a move toward
convincing people that they ought not be
on welfare in the first place that takes
a moral shift in the culture and that's
something that I mean that's what I do
every day that's why I'm here because I
think that's actually important Todd
says do you have any insight as to how
people from the same religious
background can be raised with two
conflicting political viewpoints not
really which is why I think that you
should marry somebody who has the same
ideological viewpoint you do I says for
example you have mentioned that being
raised Jewish is why you are
conservative alternatively one of the
host of positive America stated that
being raised in a Jewish family is the
reason he's a Democrat okay that's
because he wasn't raised in a Jewish
family he's raised in an ethnically
Jewish family where they like bagels and
lox and think that everybody's
anti-semitic and they visit shul once a
year on Yom Kippur and break for lunch
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna challenge
that contention that Jewishness makes
you reform I mean the Jewishness makes
you a liberal George Nixon makes you a
leftist if by Jewishness you mean ethnic
cultural identity and not religious
identity because I guarantee you
whichever hosts that is on polity of
America their level of Jewish observance
is probably lower than many Christians I
know the Stefon says can you explain the
difference between the Reagan tax cuts
and the tax cuts that just passed so the
Reagan tax cuts my understanding is that
they were largely individually based
they're all about lowering the
individual tax rates the the top tax
bracket was dropped from something like
70% to 28%
it was radically eliminated all the tax
brackets were moved down in pretty
substantial ways in fact you know what I
want to get this answer for you you know
in a little bit more detail so I'm
actually gonna look up the details of
the Reagan tax cuts so the Reagan tax
cuts were not basically corporate it
spurred a lot of economic growth the top
rate it was it was basically it was
lowering the top tax bracket so the top
rate fell from 70% to 50% and the and
all of the other tax rates dropped
similarly the 86
tax bill was also was also very
different than this one the reason that
people say this is serious tax reform is
because it changes the corporate tax
rate in a major way this person this
particular tax rate again was was based
in corporate taxation less than in an
individual taxation in the I'm gonna
wiki this ok so here's here's what
wikipedia says doctor Wikipedia he says
in the Act wasn't across-the-board
decrease in the marginal income tax
rates in the United States by 25 percent
over 3 years with the top tax rate
falling from 70 to 50 percent the bottom
rate dropping from 14 percent to 11
percent it slashed estate taxes and trim
taxes paid by Business Corporations by
150 billion over a five year period but
most of the tax decreases were in the
individual area it was less based on
corporate taxation this one there were
sort of minor cuts to the individual tax
rates but there was major cuts to the
corporate tax rates that's the major
difference between the two sets of taxes
okay crystal says hey Ben what would you
say is the best evidence for god what
gives you a reason to believe thanks for
all you do my husband I listen to your
show every day and discuss it together
we're big fans so I'm writing a book on
this the best evidence for God as I have
said on the show before and as I say in
debate with sam Harris which i think is
going to he'll be putting that out
pretty soon if he hasn't already the
basic idea is that if you believe in
free will if you believe in human reason
if you believe in our capacity to
understand the universe if you believe
in a predictable universe with laws that
govern it if you believe we do not live
in a chaotic universe without meaning if
you believe that you can derive aught
from is then you need to believe in a
divine creator okay and that's is not
that's not an argument for the Bible but
that's it that is an argument for God
right that's that's the Aristotelian
argument for God is that there is a
rationale behind everything if you
believe there's a rationale behind
everything then you believe in God and
if you believe as Aquinas did that that
rationale is purely actual right here
here's sort of the argument that
Aristotle makes the error is the
argument that Aristotle makes for the
unmoved mover is not that everything has
a cause and therefore there's God
because then leftist and atheists just
say well that's what what does God have
a cause also right the idea is that
there that everything that you see in
front of you at one point was another
thing that was actualized right there
there's to that something has potential
and there's the potential in the actual
right like this piece of paper right
here this has the potential
to be ash but it requires fire in order
to make it ash now fire itself also had
a potential at one point right it was a
match and it was a piece of wood or it
was a rough surface so it had the
potential to be fire but it was not fire
so in order for something to become
actual in order for potential to be
actualized it has to be acted upon by
something that is either fully actual or
something that is a combination of the
actual with its own potential the idea
here would be that there is something
that relies behind everything that is
purely actual right it is actuality
itself it is the most actual thing and
this thing cannot be material because of
the other material that it would have
potential for change right it doesn't
have potential for change
therefore it is purely actual and that
pure actuality also is all-knowing
because anything that exists has to come
from a place of it has to come from a
place of a capacity for for being
actualized and so it's the unnatural
eyes to actualize err is the way that
God would be put if you want to read a
good book about proofs of God then
Edward phasor is a book I've recommended
on the show he has five proofs for the
existence of God quite of the book and I
recommend you check it out good
Christmas rate actually I would
recommend that you check that out again
I think when it comes down to in the end
is you either believe there's a purpose
and meaning in human life or you don't
if you don't you may end up in a theist
if you do you're gonna end up at God no
matter how you slice it and any attempts
to avoid that which is the debate I had
with Sam Harris any attempts to avoid
that conclusion are bound to fall short
Aaron says any tips on asking for a
raise I love my workplace but my boss is
pretty cheap my advice is that you
actually make a list of your
accomplishments and that you go in with
another job offer in hand right that you
actually go out and investigate the
market well then you say look I love
working here but I can make more money
elsewhere are you gonna meet that or you
gonna keep me don't make Bluffs I'm not
I'm not big into Bluffs and I don't like
bluffing even in poker I'm not good at
bluffing I think that bluffing is a
fool's errand so be ready to pull the
trigger if you want to pull the trigger
let's see jason says he mentioned it was
a mistake to have an income tax what
would you do instead if it were up to
you other than huge spending cuts of
course so I think there's a strong case
for national sales tax that on
transactions the government taxes
basically because
transactions can only take place in
public square so certain extent that
that seems to me a consumption tax seems
to me more useful than an income tax
because no business of the governments
what kind of money I make but presumably
if I'm acting in the public square then
they may have more of an interest in the
transactions in which I take play in
which I take part although they should
have not obviously restrict consensual
transactions Jimmy says Ben what is your
opinion on privatized versus publicly
run prisons the only reason for publicly
run prisons how it assumes that you
don't want to set up a corrupt system
whereby privatized prisons are
attempting to create more criminals but
yeah I don't really have a problem with
privatized prisons particularly if you
hold them liable for mistreatment of
prisoners right if they actually signed
contracts with the state let's say that
we can sue you if you mistreat the
prisoners if you harm the prisoners that
actually creates more accountability not
less public systems have very little
accountability Elvises what's your take
on the high prices of legal services it
seems like most cases result in
settlements simply to avoid the high
cost of legal process money shouldn't
impact justice right though the reason
that you have high prices on legal
services is because everybody goes to
court for every reason so what you
should do instead is we should set up a
system like Britain's where if you sue
and you lose you pay the bills if you do
that that's going to prevent people from
going to court with frivolous cases
Stephen says had it been celebrate New
Year's one glass of wine or one bottle I
celebrate New Year's by deciding who to
destroy in the coming year that's how I
celebrate New Year's I and I mean
honestly it's a strain from even to stay
up till midnight on New Year's the
Jewish New Year was already in Rosh
Hashanah and we made not just New Year's
resolutions but commitments to God so
New Year is like getting going to party
and getting drunk with people I'm not
big on getting drunk with anybody in
NASA I'm really not a big drinker is the
truth like yesterday everyone at the
Christmas party got some form of
alcoholic gift which is why productivity
at the company is so low but I am I'm
not a big drinker
for some reason a lot of alcohol really
gives me heartburn which is weird wine
particularly but I the the III drink
like a girl I mean all of the drinks
that I like our girls rings I like I
like things that taste good I don't
understand why guys have this macho
thing about drinking turpentine they sit
around and they sit around smoking on
leaves and drinking turpentine and it's
like why would you do that there's a
thing called sugar try it it's great
okay moshe says hi Ben I'm a medium I'm
from a
medium-to-large modern orthodox
community New York recently there's been
some controversy when a local synagogue
wouldn't allow a married lesbian couple
to join the membership even though they
were separate members when they were
single if sin started their own show
which promotes acceptance of all it's
caused a bit of controversy in the
neighborhood where some are saying a
religious institution should adhere to a
religious standard others are pointing
out there are plenty of people who sin
why should this seam be held to a
different standard regarding membership
in the show I was wondering what your
take is on Modern Orthodox Scholz taking
on same-sex couples as members so my
answer is that they cannot join us a
couple right that's the answer is that
from a religious standard they cannot
join us a couple they do not get the
same rights as married couples they
should not be treated as a married
couple because that's the religious
standard now I don't think the
government has anything to do here but
the religious standard in Judaism is
that homosexuality is a sin not
homosexual orientation but homosexual
activity you wouldn't allow somebody to
join your Orthodox shul who came in
every day right who came into the shul
on Saturdays with their cellphone
blaring and saying I'm a non Sabbath
observant Jew and I'm here to Domon and
doing it openly there's one thing that
they come in with the cell phone in the
pocket and it goes off and it reads a
little bit awkward but the whole point
here is that glorification of sin in an
Orthodox context is not a cool thing so
I think that's right that they're
allowed to be members when they're
single now that they're married if they
want to join as single members that's
fine but I don't think that's what they
want what they really want is for the
entire community to change its standard
of marriage to meet them and that seems
to me an imposition on the community
okay so we have more questions but we'll
have to save those for for next year
we'll have to save those for next year
now a quick thing I like and then a
thing I hate and then I have a quick
message of things actually I'm capable
of saying it yes indeed okay so things I
like so we're gonna finish the year on a
high note with some John way and so if
you've never seen this movie it's
actually one of my favorite John Wayne
movies it was not a huge hit but it is
really enjoyable the movie is called Big
Jake and starts old John Wayne and and
Maureen O'Hara who remained gorgeous her
entire life and the basic premise it's
basically taken about a Western that's
really what it is it's it's these these
guys who come and kidnap a child and
John Wayne is the grandfather and John
Wayne goes after them and he brings
along a couple of his sons right who are
the uncles of the kid and in them in the
movie one of his sons is actually
by Patrick Wayne John Wayne's real son
then the movie takes place in supposedly
1908 so you see there there's a couple
of cars but he's riding horses and so
there's also this sort of Western versus
modern conflict that's going on where
John Wayne represents sort of the Old
West and you need the Old West to come
into the modern world and save people
when the bad guys show up it's a really
enjoyable flick here's a little bit of
the preview I just saw something in your
eyes I don't like I saw a foolish
thought you understand me anything
happens anything at all your fault my
fault nobody's fault my little brother
will blow that kid's head right off
it's as simple as that no matter who
else gets killed that boy dies shotgun
misses him at the Manor you already know
about the rifle on him that won't be as
messy as a shotgun at three feet but
that boy will be just as dead you
understand me
say it I understand
now open it up
all right so we'll cut it off there
because this seam gets pretty intense
the other son is played by Christopher
Mitchum who is Robert Mitchum son so
that's kind of fun and it's worth
watching the best performance in it is
Richard Boone who plays the villain here
and the movie is is really good it's
pretty bloody it basically it didn't
occur to me until I was looking at this
yes yet you know until I was looking at
this yesterday that this is taken the
movie is taken but it's in old Western
with John Wayne and it it lives up to
the hype okay time for a quick thing I
hate one thing I hate and then I have a
message so the thing I hate today is
something that you will like and that is
we made a Christmas message from the
daily wire to you I have to acknowledge
that this was my idea so I can't hate it
completely but now that it has
materialized in real life form its I
sort of hate it so here it is here is a
here's our Christmas video from The
Daily wire to you thank you so much
right now
[Laughter]
[Music]
and I just want to say a couple of quick
messages really for Christmas in the in
the new year it's a great time of the
season to spend time with friends and
family and let's remember something we
spend a lot of time on the show a lot of
time on the show talking about politics
and the daily battles they're in and one
of the things I've been thinking about
over the last couple of years and I'm
writing a book about it now is we're so
angry at each other all the time
Americans are so angry at each other
over politics over tax cuts and
Obamacare and foreign policy and the
reality is we must have a common vision
a common purpose we must feel like we're
part of the same team and one of the
ways to do that is to recognize that we
are all seeking human happiness in a in
a communal purpose based on virtue so
this Christmas don't just spend time
enjoying with family think about how to
be a more virtuous human being next year
think about how to be a better person
not just in terms of interpersonal
connections but how you can be better in
terms of thinking about your obligations
to your family to the world in pilot how
can you make yourself better how can you
make yourself more successful if we all
think about those things we think about
our individual purpose how we can
succeed in our own lives we think that
our communal purpose what brings us
together around common shared principles
then we'll finally have a country worthy
of preserving again and a country where
you know we can we can act on that
founding vision that brought us all
together in the first place and then I
think has been fragmenting in the past
couple of years we are all brothers and
sisters whether we recognize it or not
and in the end we're part of the same
family but that family has to have a
common purpose not just a common
heritage so let's let's think about
where to go from here I also want to
thank everybody who works on the show
over here at the Daily wire I want to
thank all of my producers I'm not gonna
name all of them because I'm sure they
don't forget somebody and be yelled at
later so just check out the credits at
the end of the show but everybody who
works really hard day to day on the show
they do they work extremely hard to cut
the clips play the clips at the right
time
make sure the clip is not available for
playing Marshall they really work hard
to to make sure that the show is as good
as it is every day and they deserve my
thanks and so
really from the bottom my heart it's
great to be part of the team with you we
couldn't do it without you and finally
thank you to our audience this has been
an unbelievable year for The Daily wire
it's been an incredible year for the
Daily wire when we literally went from a
site that did not exist two years ago to
a site with 100 million page views a
month when went from a podcast that did
not exist two years ago to a podcast
that is downloaded well in excess of
half a million times a day and that is
viewed another half a million times on
Facebook very often so we have a million
people engaging with the show on a daily
basis that's thanks to you thanks for
being part of what we're trying to do
here and thanks for giving us a rational
hearing and if you're on the other side
particularly thanks to you freshly
spending some time out of your comfort
zone and listening to some folks on the
other side because I think that it makes
the country better if we all do that
I'll see you next year
it's been it's been a wonderful year
thanks once again and have a very Merry
Christmas and a wonderful new year i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jael para the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing